[Music]
[Music]
what is uh good morning everyone welcome
back to GameSpot live it's been a loopy
morning it's those Mondays Monday
technical issues anyway thank you all
for joining us I'm Ritchie I'm here with
David we are playing a little more Tim
Tim because we are gonna get our shot at
it
we tried during the Alpha stages you
guys loved it a lot
we tried during the real day one it was
a struggle it was an MMO launch wasn't
it it was it was very rough but we're
here we're back and we're playing on
David's account we're late so let's just
get into it huh Oh perfect looks like
it's looking good which is which is nice
yeah you got online pretty smoothly
there I did excellent it seems like what
they did was they kind of streamlined
the amount of people that were in any
instance at one time she was like if you
remember and once I get out of this
little battle right here for those of
you who have been following the early
access there's a lot less people right
now there are there were tons people
running around now there they are
there's a few there's a lot like it is
you know back then it was like literally
hundreds of people in one eye when you
got in there were a bunch of people
battling in that little grassy patch
that standing around they would all be
in the same battle with the same trainer
and it would just it cost the game to
crash every single time jeez it was it
was something it looks a lot better now
it looks a lot smoother yes people the
the initial hype has it has calmed down
a little we're able to get into the game
and play right away yeah the it does
seems like the frame rate will drop a
bit oh really yeah
whenever someone like spots you or
before you start a match it looks fine
right now mm-hmm but I was just noticing
that when I when I was first playing wow
this is a big temp temp that is I've
seen one of those before though didn't
we catch him I think I know we fought
one we fought one in the dojo something
we've been through this stuff like
through the ringer during the Alpha
stress test right we went all the way to
that dojo
yeah there was no there didn't seem to
be a limit on that alpha how far you can
go which was cool y'all goin live with
Tim Tim again has me most sure yeah and
we got some we got some love for Kobe
Bryant big very weird big loss yesterday
yesterday was so weird I couldn't
believe it it was a shock dude I
remember just waking up and like it was
completely yeah but we're not trying to
get to press peek no it's Monday we need
less of them we need less what happy
thoughts tempt my eternally just like
went down as soon as I remember but yeah
we got we got 10 Sam we don't want to
get my [ __ ] no even though Akash is back
in the building
what's up here we are I'm not trying to
be my shift today but shook Mondays hmm
although I do like that we played every
Monday we call it more shook Mondays
what do you guys think
hello boys father those dad in the chat
what's up thanks for joining us we're
you guys prom I love I'd love to do that
every now and then in the chat like yeah
where you shout out where you're from
[Music]
Floyd says Pokemon I'm upset how come
you didn't have a game like this first
move them that's that's a pretty common
opinion people are loving this gamer
like it's easy to compare to obviously
but people are mad that like the idea a
lot of these ideas were never
implemented at any Pokemon game but you
know just play some Tim Tim you know
good game
keep playing Pokemon though because
that's never gonna go as much as I have
fun with this you know yeah it's got the
pedigree the moment that this game comes
out on console in the future I think it
might be like next year or later this
year did you have been given a final
announcement but think about kids who
end up growing up with this stuff if
they do it's gonna happen dude yeah I
want this on the switch
it'll be perfect I think I switch I
think this is a great game on the switch
yeah I'm actually I don't know I mean I
haven't even thought about it but I'm
playing mouse and keyboard right now I
usually plug in the controller yeah but
it's good you know what I thought about
the a big red flag obviously on switch
and wouldn't work unless here like
within Wi-Fi you can't really take it to
go anywhere but oh my god do you think
ask mm Oh like I don't know what I'm
thinking wow yeah we have to play this
at home it's always online right yeah
offline version if there is then that's
a game changer but it seems like such a
big a pillar this game is yeah man they
gotta start making those switches like
they did with the Vita's with like Porgy
built-in you know that'd be dope hey we
have some people from New Zealand to
make us oh my god I love it Sweden
Illinois what's up yeah there we go yeah
so cool I got one of my best friends
lives in Illinois Providence Rhode
Island a shout-out to you thank you all
for joining us around the world to play
a little tempt him what shook Mondays
OHS kono
hell yeah I'll cost from Canada a nice
school we love Canada
Brandon Hernandez recognized you as well
welcome back Brandon is back from LA oh
wow yeah there you go he needs a good
start to the week too
you're on the same like timezone as uh
same state and everything man welcome to
you all
thank you tempers got a good idea you
saying yeah you'd like it on the iPhone
and I think it is supposed to come was
it okay I don't I don't want to misspeak
but I think I remember that too like
that'd be cool because you do have data
on your phone it's why not or it just
seems like such a no-brainer right like
it's hard to tell but got some love from
the UK woohoo yeah Argentina it's
wonderful currently yes Warren this is
for PC only and that's how we're playing
today it's on Steam now's the time to
join man things have calmed down and you
can get in and actually play because we
tried last was it last week early last
week and it was tough it was could not
get in it was last week I remember I
felt really bad her show though it was
like just admirably going through the
wiki and like finding out all these cool
facts yeah and we were just staring at
the queue we were like up to like 20,000
in lines you guys in chat that worked
great because they they held it down the
whole time they were they were here with
us they knew this struggle it's not like
it was our fault but they were there and
understanding I remember that day very
well we're all very happy got some love
from the Philippines here yeah
oh my god benign Kasia shook mondays and
fun with Friday oh yeah I love that you
gotta make some apparel dude I know
we're already getting merged deals from
Akash in the chat we need hats B's
sweaters yeah
iPhone cases Warren says my PC is too
old dang it I have that problem too I
moved into a small apartment I never set
up my PC because there's no really
anywhere to put it and then it just got
older and older and I never updated now
I'm Sol man F in the chat for warrants
PC and Richy speak yeah because I know
that struggle all too well I mean while
your boy here's got like a friggin eye 9
processor oh yeah damn at work it's a
different story but at home yeah nope
come here to play games for sure at
least PC games right and a lot of
editing to do we need powerful computers
at work a lot of encoding a lot of
rendering huge ass terabytes of like
hard drive space oh yeah very nice here
but it needs to be that way
we cannot yeah y'all editors know what
it's like is this the same gameplay as
Pokemon at its core yeah absolutely you
you capture Tim Tim you should have a
starter Tim Tim you battle them you can
find them in the wild you find other
trainers although they're called tamers
here yeah tamer stammers in watching
from Elsa though I'd love to ask that
sometimes it just it just goes over my
head how the reach yeah we we sometimes
have so thank you all for being here
yeah got some apps for the chat akaash
thank you yep hard ask man I got nothing
at home I have a well let's put it this
way all I have at home is like
book and no way let's not even open that
can of worms good for editing is about
it it's unfortunate that for gaming Macs
have like they just use integrated
graphics you know what I mean you can't
not the problem I just always known ok
that's that stinks and then they're like
$4,000
you know versions it's like it only has
like a Radeon graphics card or something
or like Jacob you're watching from work
what you doing man you better be on
break yeah
thanks for joining us I guess dude come
on we're not we're not supporting people
you know taking bring some work but also
thanks for yeah for real though I'm a
low like appreciate you yeah does this
game have waifu's uh
David you might want to take that one I
have no idea is there any love interest
in this story at all maybe we haven't
made it that far
yeah look you have a little girlfriend
already we're talking about oh okay yeah
and Max is jealous Warren says I will
just play on my xbox there you go you
know what a dope I don't know if we've
mentioned this in today's what is that I
did I did was that that Mohawk dudes
Pope a Pokemon mm that's gonna battle me
but I what was that was like someone
else's that was that was cool it looked
like legendary almost yeah man well
Warren I was gonna say this has plans
for the future for all console releases
and possibly mobile I think mobile maybe
maybe no now you know what yeah we don't
wanna confirm that but uh definitely all
the consoles so I'm in the same boat as
you I can't really play this yet I
played it I work quite a lot but
not at home someday I think 2021 they're
saying yeah you know Akash has at least
the content is safe for work I mean
that's right yeah if someone
accidentally hears you listening to us
you're fine
Akash always says I swear max is always
jealous yeah man he's like the Gary man
he's he's just upset all the time
even though you're a better temp temp
tamer there we go no scary there was
some lag there well the dude wanted me
to get a little vial to go speak to
someone but there you go we have to get
that tumescence vial oh I remember that
yeah no worries he says Pavan am I
seeing the right will it come to PC yeah
we're playing on PC now it's actually
only available on PC at the moment is it
out on Steam Philip asks yes that's
exactly how we're playing today Jacob
says glad this is a thing I bought it
just so game free can have some actual
competition you know what that's fine
that seems to be a lot of people's
motive cuz uh there may be Pokemon
shouldn't have like the monopoly on it
although they invented the the style and
the genre for sure but like have another
game have an alternative that's fine
with me and it's been fun overall it's
been fun the tumescent you have to fight
him no no I have to find that some
essence I just don't remember where to
get it
me neither I remember the name of that
thing was
how to get it though hey that guy's name
was thug life maybe thug life knows
where to get Tim essence was there a
person or a store I feel like it was
just wanted me to buy like regular yes
hmm I wasn't paying attention to Sophie
oh and she's telling me but I feel like
she mentioned it let's see here
yeah you want to look it up yeah oh yeah
I'm not above that at all tumescence
Maya it Google Auto filled my answer
let's see here how to get the tumescent
vial mmm it's part of the first steps
quest are you in mayor no strim right no
thank you
I got a cache attempts emerald look at
the map if you press em you'll know
exactly where to go this map has a
picture and everything oh maybe yeah
yeah dude here but I think I have to
catch a time son first well we'll talk
to this guy real quick just to see oh
you have to catch a wild one there's so
many people in you see you must have
cost my attempts at bring me any time
say okay so I got to go catch one dang
it all good yeah this will be easier of
course when we want to pick a fight
there you okay oh you remember how like
insanely common we're running into yes
yeah oh the encounter rate David would
you scootch in a little to your right
you're like a little bit Larry would you
like this exactly it's very casual now
but I do that all the time in that chair
specifically to
it's an easy thing to do plus I think is
cause like the mic there you go there we
go Jacob back at it again he says I will
have this on in the background wall I
quote work amen
he'll get in trouble we won't that we're
gonna pretend we don't know you if that
happening man
shrill voice its back that's the best
attack shrill voices bomb because it
hurts both of them yeah you can't use it
right off the bat for some reason which
is weird is weird perfect you didn't
knock him out I did not the one thing I
will say that I don't like is when you
use the tense em card mm-hmm that should
just be it but now it wants me to like
move again which is dumb cuz it's like
you know I plan on using this card to
have to use it I just like I don't know
it's weird that is weird so instead of
attacking your move is now to use the
chemcam card it's like yeah it's like it
takes the role of a right mmm that's
like a Pokemon even if it was a 2v2 or
whatever the moment you shoes like throw
the ball it's over you throw it yeah hmm
interesting
hello extra step there ash in the chat
says I'm with Jacob this is my morning
start at work cool nice starting off
your day with a little what do we call
it
imma shook Mondays yeah awesome we
appreciate you joining us yeah oh yeah a
wild uh Lulu asks will you lose progress
with Tim Tim leaves early access great
question yeah
go ahead David I mean we we learn this
we did lose we lost progress during the
alpha test yeah it tells you though it's
very clear it's like the first green but
I did not get
thing telling me that it was gonna lose
access like right off the bat but just
from the nature of things they do put
like a really big warning saying like
hey this is a work in progress so things
can go you know haywire don't be
surprised if something happens if you're
like alright yeah but you know
nice crystal dust bro crystal Dez I
remember that move yeah
it's another good one oh it also gives
you two tries to catch it the first one
fails though
oh that's neither that's kind of cool
the COS says I'm surprised you guys
aren't doing the coop Tim Tim didn't
know that was a thing no well like just
in terms of FML like we could
technically oh yeah I could be on this
computer and we can play it I've been
playing man that's too much screen
capturing streaming problems although
that's fine that's a fun idea I think
we've done that for COD before purchase
played on this screen but we're
recording this one no no because she
swapped over to hers without Persia
where I'm s you guys I don't know if you
know that's why the stream was late
today
we miss you Persia yeah are they like
bothering me though or cannot or not cuz
some people can just live with them and
you Mikan you might just be able to dude
you're gonna be wise for the rest of
your life I had all four minor move let
me just let that put put that in
perspective I am no longer rich either
wise it's funny because I actually have
like a gap in my front seat and it was
way worse back in the day but oh your
wisdom teeth pushed them they've been
pushing em close the gap yeah it's like
it's like knockoff ray she's interesting
damn some free braces yeah I have a
little gap too but I never got braces
from those attacking Tim Tim crystals
must hurt the other tempt him
nikasha Zane looks like a hurt yeah
[Music]
yay Pig a pic right yeah that one's my
favorite so far
oh yeah yeah you just so cute I love I
love pigs Maya my old roommate had a pet
teacup pig really
oh the micro pigs did it like stay small
no okay all right lied to you probably
paid more for that those little teacup
pigs are those micro pigs they're cute
but they're like these they're no
they're unnatural I guess to say the
least but there's so damn cute but
people buy them yeah cos from Richie
otherwise to Richie Rich or Richie
Tozier I love that I like what do we
call me grandpa Richie and you're young
and Dave I have many nicknames here one
you guys gave me was sprout which is
probably my favorite sprout yeah for we
were playing uh plants vs. zombies oh
that one but the chat nickname is sprout
and we had a good time and then pers
even changed my name on the lower third
[Laughter]
buddy oh man you killed big a pic you
monster and I don't feel bad about it
oh my hearts broken let's see would you
rather play this or sword and shield
great I'm like a man game of sword and
shield
okay okay
[Music]
Oh No yeah we want educated keep saying
ir he says I keep getting real bored of
this game for some reason pain you know
it does kind of have a see me vibe to it
right how many times have you done this
whole setup it's sure especially if
you're a Pokemon fan it's perfect for
guys like me who really kind of who
haven't played Pokemon I've been off the
radar for pokemon for a lot of years so
it's like refreshing it's like starting
over like when I was a kid my first
version was red which was the very first
one but I played it at lunch I think I
stopped that like when the gameboy
advance came out I didn't buy Ruby or
sapphire so I stopped out like gold and
silver damn it wasn't it a remake of one
of red or what am I thinking of like
leaf green ingot fire red fire red yeah
yeah I missed the boat for a year for
decades on this dude but I started it
off as a you know og Pokemon fan just
bought Ritchie over here my B my gameboy
color no I had a regular Gameboy for a
while it was just like great yeah I was
struggling no light or anything but I
got a gameboy color for Christmas one of
those purple ones their bricks dude with
the small screen that's the worst part
like this is like nowadays this is all
screen yeah but like that thing was like
a calculator dude no light or anything
people keep picking fights
I got a train the guys are very like
anime haircut
is there a pokedex type thing yes there
is right yeah it's in the menu yeah for
sure
I forget how extensive it is but like
there's gotta be at least some
description or something like that it's
definitely there like your Pokemon
master no she's really good these Queen
around here absolutely but I like it
feels good over for a while you Kelly
and Jake were doing those were they
those big battles or the ball
yeah the raids that's just exciting but
everyone those kind of came to Pokemon
go same deal you had to go walk and find
them and then you all had a chance to
catch them I like this squid Tim Tim
though colossal odds
burn his eyes really cool I missed it
they cut away soon it looks like oh yeah
there they are
okay cool Akash asks have you played the
recent Pokemon games yeah David
especially even the latest one sword and
shield we were just talking about that
that's sick I haven't done that let's
see the last series I played every game
for was like Kingdom Hearts god that's a
mmm I don't wanna open that can of worms
but quinoa yeah geez dude I played them
all because I loved one so much it was
like chasing the hi of how I felt when I
played one dude no other game lived up
it stings I really liked I liked three
three was like the closest thing to the
one two and three are like solid but I
went out and bought you know a DSPs
PlayStation Portable the PSP you know
very precisely yeah for all the games
that came out on every other console
I bought a Game Boy Advance SP dude none
of those games were really worth that's
not entirely true but they weren't as
good as one that's all I'm trying to say
is this for ps4 ask Tyler nope not yet
but it is planned to be right now we're
planning on Steam it's the only way to
play but they have plans for an Xbox
release of PlayStation release even a
switch release I think right I don't
want to double check that I got the
computer right here let's see
hmmm maybe it was mobile that's what I'm
thinkin out because this is a massive
MMO so you do need that internet man
well you know you can't okay it is
announced for the switch to you probably
gotta play it at home dock with like you
know Wi-Fi or meta Starbucks or whatever
you guys play games out in the public
like that like I don't I don't tend to
go anywhere and use like Wi-Fi for much
I don't like to work out in there I'd
rather just be home big same man this is
going smoothly so far though as far as
like performance we're not getting
kicked out there's no glitches what I
remember this lady really yeah I don't
I only remember the dojo person in that
one that one like chick rich like the
leader of
vilandra oh the fake Team Rocket we kept
going do characters evolve oh yeah they
do they do but evolution I've been a
broken record our chat needs to hear but
evolution doesn't it doesn't work like
in Pokemon we're ten times evolved at a
certain level like if you have a friggin
Totodile it will always involve it a
Crockett on at level 18 or higher no
matter what right that is its base right
but in in temp time it's different
your starter isn't going to evolve at
level 30 it's going to evolve after you
level it up 30 times so if you got it at
frickin level 1 and you haven't evolved
at 31 if you got it at level 10 it's
gonna ball back 40 like it's more of oh
yeah okay it's more look at how that's
interesting it's a different way to
approach it for sure but it sounds like
a lot longer it says a lot it's a lot
longer right because you can't kind of
like pokemons right yeah yeah after
something close
it's interesting well the ones in the
wild we're finding are all low-level but
they still take equally long to evolve
let's see
I had the chat up here on the right the
other day remember that that was nice I
don't know how I did that it's hard to
read your names cuz I'm kind of far from
the monitor but we have a question here
beyond a possible Pokemon s experience
for multiplayer platforms what does
tempt em do better so because I'm so
biased well you know what yeah that's a
tough qualified but there are some
things that sometimes does better I
guess maybe in terms of well for one I
wouldn't say it's what it does better
but what it just different right yeah
cuz one Pokemon is not an MMO and the
online seems to be the focal point of
semsem whereas online always kind of
felt a little more like this mainline
campaign and then you get to the end
game and it seems like they keep
changing their online every generation
might have been might have been Diamond
and Pearl where the WTS was first made
for online WCS it's like a world trade
okay and it was cool but then they like
got rid of it and now they're trying to
do a new thing with like Pokemon home
but it's only working with you know
certain
one bank and you know what that sounds
like a very nintendo problem like they
not problem but they like to experiment
a lot they hook big things and small
things like the 3d s was kind of a
experiment but they've also had a lot of
failures like the Virtual Boy they try
to push a lot of experimental things and
since Game Freak and Nintendo are in
cahoots like they probably implement
this these weird internet when that and
cuz of Nintendo yeah sure
I'm guessing anyway no it's it's it's a
good guess and it's kind of where
something would like the Virtual Boy you
might not invest as much into it when it
comes to things like you know the Wii U
right exactly or the original Wii that
but what I was trying to say with the
Wii is like sometimes though their risks
pay off like the Wii was the biggest
thing in gaming for like not just me
it's not for gamers actually but for
like families and people outside of
gaming it brought people in which is
nuts
anyway we got a little off there but hey
look paradox acres in the chat hey guys
glad you're able to access the game this
time you have a lot - yeah we're so
happy to be here online day one was a
little rough but you guys were there for
us then here for us now appreciate you
in the chat today how's everyone doing
what sort of functionality does tempt
him have for online connectivity oh
would you do I missed it I meant to use
up all
and I just used the tens'up cards and
said oh that's hilarious
I kind of have this question to like
what what sort of what is tempting offer
for online connectivity between players
like you see them running around but
like for sure he like befriend them are
just I haven't really seen any
outstanding benefits to like the MMO
aspect the end so Callie has done a
great write-up on Sam toes it's Ryan
what it does and she when she was
playing it she was doing it to be to
co-op so right that's a thing for sure
does and she had a lot of good things to
say she had a lot of suggestions for
improvement as well for sure for sure
but yeah but it seems like essentially
you can so you can interact with people
if you have a friends list which I don't
yeah you can probably get racula there
you can type in the tamer ID to search
hey yeah what's your actually it might
not I forget I think it is Ritchie's
rich yeah oh three e's in the middle
there i think i think that's why i named
myself was it only with the alpha oh you
know what yeah forget it well good to
know that Ritchie's isn't taken and you
didn't befriend another Ritchie's out in
the wild I should have killed up I'm
totally Akash says re P crystal
Oh Danza Oh paradox says honestly these
temp temp creatures are growing on me
yeah man me too I mean I found them
I haven't played Pokemon in quite a
while but I'm feeling that these designs
are like for the starters maybe we won't
talk about that but the rest of them
they're pretty original like these
little guys are funny it's got to be
really creative manic imagine coming up
oh yeah for the thousand how many
Pokemon are there no David a lot yeah
and then like not taking any direct
inspiration from them to create your own
list of temptin right they're gonna look
at the same at some point some of them
but I think they're good they're doing a
good job of their base 160 161 161 yeah
summarize that I like how they look -
that's all good at least looking like
yeah you're fine that one on the left is
cool yeah yeah I like that one a lot
one thing I think I have seen that
before I don't know damn they kick you
all the way back o to the town to the
sound F the name Tim Tim sounds exactly
like Tintin a popular European cartoon
says gage cool
what's the cartoon about oh yeah you're
right is it that little kid I think so
it's not a tensioner it's Tim Tim but
you're right which was also basically a
little blond kid yeah adventures of
tintin with a little he has the cowlick
on his head oh yeah get some more
recruits spoke too soon I can't be
saying that Kirsty damn man remember
last time you guys were looking at the
wiki that [ __ ] came up fast like the
community is on it that that wiki was
like filled out to the max it's so
impressive
so got him there you did get them this
time
yeah I said it afterwards man rematch
time I'm catching loads
[Music]
that's cool hair your hair your hair is
cool too you got that like ombre green
right there
[Music]
oh I saw that yeah you can definitely
buy more clothes too and like edit your
hair color I randomized mine as soon as
I started and it had a pink mohawk
it's pretty funny evolution ask what is
the similarities between Tim Tim of
Pokemon tons types attacks a lot of
similarities those examples you listed
the types and attacks are probably the
biggest ones like there are types the
attacks your Chin's like your villains
like it's pretty similar to some early
Pokemon for sure but I want to go back
on that list that wiki list that we love
so much because I want to read off the
types the temp temp types
just for you evolution our Neutral fire
nature water electric mental earth wind
crystal digital melee and toxic so pair
them how you will compare them how you
will with Pokemon ties but it sounds
pretty damn similar to me so much so
many similarities in what would you say
mental was again psychic sigh kids yeah
digital that one's fun digital this one
I think digital is a little different
than pain in the chest is gang gang gang
we that's us we are gameplay team
primarily focused on just putting raw
gameplay on our GameSpot gameplay
channel which you can find on YouTube
yes and we should just call ourselves a
gang gameplay gang what you see right so
that was a super effective attack did
you see like a red star them yeah times
half that means half gamma rights like
very effective like that you got a
quarter damage right there quarter
damage is even worse right that two
types or weeks yeah I think this one is
a
electric flying uh-huh whatever so a
wind attack against a right it's not
like I'm sorry just like they're
absolutely correct
they were like stronger tags for you
know the types of Pokemon you are
attempting to fight same things oh this
guy that's how my character looking
except he had white skin
really yeah but the random character I
generated when I started this thingy
going exactly he has those Brock eyes
are like oh yeah someone shared that in
our chat the other day is like his
username was not Rock and he he had a
green shirt brown vest the almost a
Brock hair and those eyes that are like
clenched shut so oh you know who I miss
though guile
style USA Oh a and twitch chat also was
a player we saw on the Alpha days and I
think like we actually I ran into the
real not glad the other Italian on like
the first oh dang okay whoa that's what
that squid guy evolves into Calibos yeah
dude huge is there a third form I hate
to see that was dairy dude it's
that's a gnarly rip crystal Oh No Akash
I don't know man yes how did how on
earth did Brock have those eyes anyway
this is a look man
he's always stressed out Oh Tim Tim gang
cave travel and water travel are the
worst in here than it is in Pokemon
though it's worse in here than it is in
Pokemon interesting hmm it was very you
know what David did address that the
encounters in the caves and yeah no I do
remember that now it was heavy they were
bad but you you explained that they kind
of smooth that out and they made the
encounters a little less frequent so if
we make it to the caves today hopefully
it'll be nice that door still says a
work in progress with a lot of them a
lot of them do I wonder maybe need like
a key not just working progress it's not
ready yet have you guys in the chat been
able to play Tim Tim yet it's only on
Steam but I know I haven't outside of
work how about you guys ooh winter in
the chat says this is just a bad copy of
Pokemon ouch
you know what if you're a die-hard
Pokemon fan you have every right to say
that we love it though we don't see that
as a bad thing
oh they're like hey fool 2 V 2 to V 2
your pokemons all excite your tent your
10/10 was like fluttering around like
let's fight
yeah I've made that mistake three times
Oh
[Music]
Akash WI T stands for work in progress
work in progress yeah so that that that
building maybe hasn't been programmed
all the way yet or maybe at some point
you can come back to it we don't know
but it said that since the Alpha yep so
where they can question me yeah got this
hey that'd be cool if we could team up
like I'm playing on this computer I mean
you both take on these guys I would be
but the Alpha didn't carry over to the
full version so it I have to like buy it
and I haven't been able to yet it's like
35 bucks I think yeah 30 years I think
you're right it was like $34.99 I don't
know let's don't sale
Derek in the chat welcome back man it's
good to see you he says the ones hating
on Tim Tim never cut a mute - and it
shows competition is great for Game
Freak you know what I'm not gonna
disagree gumption it's always great them
you to stuff those pretty funny it
forces people to do better oh come on
don't make sub two sub I can't have that
in the chat you guys do that here with
that can we expect more games in the
future on Tim Tim you know what is it
like a tempting secret yeah I mean I
think that's still a ways off right yeah
this just launched but I wouldn't count
it out this is doing really well I think
for the company crema is that them great
the developers grandma I know they're
based in Spain yeah grandma since for
our translates to cream so I would I
wouldn't it's earth too early to tell
but I wouldn't count it out you're
asking me I wonder what the legendary
legendary Tim Tim are like I do too I
don't think so either
I don't know with me Derrick yeah you're
always here man appreciate you at what
you having we see you man you were you
were roasting me last time trying to
play close to me to see we remember that
now but we also have here pretty often
so just have you back to you more I will
say sorry it's the one thing I will say
about 10 cm is I like I have no interest
in the side quests
[Music]
there's quite a few too if they they
stack up on the right side of your
screen it's like hey help so-and-so find
this it's like hmm maybe Thanks
no thank you oh I love this this temp
temp side Pass reminds you upside dub
easy like a goofy platypus looking thing
with the funny hat though and he has
like a sigh like Raphael what is that
I'm all about it he's a little crazy
Derek remembers that day he remembers
that roast kasha can we expect other
games like Tim Tim and their
inspirations of digimon pokemon why not
I mean this may have opened the
floodgates y'all we don't know Oh
knocking even quack she's all pumped
about League that's cool here's my money
[Laughter]
yeah I just I'm gonna look up on the
wiki what Pig a Peck evolved into cuz
he's my favorite is he fire I forget
he's like a flying pig oh you're
charging motor see Akash agrees he likes
iPad too isn't he just nice he's like
cool looking funny dmoz says I don't
hate Tim Tim I've played loads of
Pokemon Pokemon clones on mobile this is
just another mm I don't know man
so it's pretty big have you played it
those demons should try it out it's
pretty fun
see ya Derrick thought that quack was
pretty cute too but unfortunately that's
the sound of him dying
I wish that were his opener like quack
quack Here I am you know I just got you
said it so matter-of-factly dude you
just like yeah unfortunately yeah that's
how it is okay I want the whole lid I'm
on the wiki right now just trying to
find a list of all of them really hmm
yeah so this is where we're going for
that we're looking for that cave right
yeah so we're just gonna mob and
[Music]
here we go this is ah why are you
wearing like a tank top and a beanie
okay you man here we go no wait
stats techniques temp temp tights
[Music]
we just search for pig a peck
[Music]
thanks but yeah yeah come on what is
evolving - whoo man this game has a
massive fan base already I'm already
seeing like artwork oh yeah you should
go to that that pokedex and then just
like control after and look up where you
fall something oh yeah okay cool he has
a luma version which is the shiny
version I believe it's cool all right so
you said the Tim Tim like Dex speaks
there you go oh yeah okay this is what I
was looking to hear all right sorry you
guys can't see my screen I'm just
looking at a list of all the tempo
akaash EVT you're too kind my friend
he says I'm a comedian with that that
dying quack
I really wasn't I guess it was the
delivery I've been mindlessly clicking
come on are there do you think there
will be clans and plan based battle
that's a good question if I look for a
pig pig there you go he's all the way
damn me I know there's nothing after
that oh well that's cool he's special
just the way he is and he's a wind type
interesting you're right cuz he could
like fly no you just like takes a little
bit of damage Akashi will forever be
associated with the dying crackling oh
my gosh
just call me side pad now that's another
nickname whatever I told you guys I
liked him engraving into the the annals
of time mark this moment what would it
be
I'll go by quack man I haven't seen a
lot of these these evolve forms are
really cool cool there I had a head of
Paro and I evolved it in the Alpha but I
didn't catch one this time because I
didn't like its final evolution really
just becomes like an old bird oh that
sucks his name is literally grandpa what
you're kidding me I'm gonna look that up
I gotta see this what was it ctrl F yeah
[Music]
grandpa yeah it looks Oh doesn't look
that great cuz when I think about like
og Pokemon I think of like Pidgeot and
Pidgeot is he's got that cool hair I
like it we got that like hipster hair I
remember people were making fun of that
Opie Giotto does the Giotto yeah Pidgeot
Pidgeot just like the layers it out yeah
okay
[Music]
quack Pat you guys are giving me all
these nicknames hey Pat sigh Pat Richie
quack Pat quite that's pretty cool man
[Music]
[Music]
y'all Wilin in the jack no likey
Oh evolution says this would be great if
the colors of this game would be a bit
more vivid and bright yeah I I have to
agree so the thing was is that in the
beginning a lot of people were vibing
with the kind of watercolor aesthetic
like it was surely sing and it is but
after a while to me it like I don't know
interesting I think it's very colorful
but you're right something about like
its saturation levels are kind of loads
that even the right size I don't hate it
though
I didn't play for that long though
hasn't weighed on me like I did with you
you played this for a few hours more
than I did I just think that like I
don't know I think I think I just want a
little more contrast I guess team is
agrees he says oh no he says that the
evil levels seemed kind of monotonous
well yeah I guess because we were
talking about the on the wiki how some
of them just don't evolve to like really
cool ones like grandpa the bird here
some little mark cool though I'm looking
at the rest of this list bigger pick is
the best though with that question
[Music]
Derek he brings up it clearly needs a
dedicated team of modders get lost bird
bird brain kick rocks although he's
really cute in his little form like that
yeah yeah it's so much promise see you
how do you guys feel about the UI some
pretty seems pretty slick and simple Oh
green I'll give you that it's not it's
not complicated for sure yeah there's
only a few options I can lick it from
what I've used it so far I'm a fan of
the way these like Pokemon centers are
set up I love the way that like you just
go to a thing you just literally press a
button and all these things come out I
don't have to talk to anybody and be
like do you want me to heal your it's
like y-yeah one reason you have one job
I like that there are like multiple
kiosks there were like eight of them
that you can refill your health because
it makes it D mez says I like the river
it looked cool the river in the stream
did look cool unfortunately there's just
like no use for it well you know what I
think I am running the temp semana isn't
there a swim ability I swear I like was
he calling Pokemon like surf but I'm in
this game I think there might be I don't
know I know they were talking about
surfboards surfboards oh yeah that's
right that's what I was thinking that
you we try to buy a surfboard and the
dude was sold out which i think is just
a plot point in the story right but we
haven't been able to yet
just run on this thing all right let's
fight look at the symptom I just got bit
you can't beat me if I use this one yeah
I love doing that I love normally a
pretty polite person but in this game
when they give me like the [ __ ]
option I'm like yeah I like to cop [ __ ]
like like yeah what's it to you yeah
fight me all these options are so mean
seriously ice cubes whoa there you go
not bad but this one's you balls right
what is this
that is the ball that's a devolution of
foam ooh bro oh man Oh move the beads
get some F's in the chat for that memory
that was fun foam ooh see I love I love
trying to get chats right and like I
know some people bad thing no I love you
I need to cuz I think it's like an
inside joke we can all laugh I you know
yeah like it's yeah
you pay respects by pressing and that's
what that's all about
I remember on during our annual extra
livestream that we did the 72 hours
stream when we like kind of raised up
for charity like Christmas time um my
first year here something had happened
it was like totally a joke and I like
yelled out I was like oh press M for
Chet and I like had daggers shot at me
like a couple people that are they're
just like everyone else on the couch or
what not everyone I don't remember who
it was but I reckon we're just like it's
a funny thing
we said I call that how many God you
guys know how many times I call that out
in the chat when like I die or when
Persia dies in the game you guys
remember see this is the family here
ever family
but yeah apps are a good thing or at
least you know we can laugh about it
good thing got him no protect pick a
pick
run away run from this battle no just
he'll pick a peck he throw bombs at him
no Matt Tony and the chat says Pokemon
greater then Tim Tim no you know what
that's okay I'm sure God how many other
millions of people feel that same way I
mean thanks for tuning in and watching
anyway man there we go we got another F
in the chat thank you
no introductions mm-hmm let's do did you
see I think it was like an anniversary
of advanced warfare or was that infinite
warfare it's been like it was a like a
five or ten year anniversary at ten of F
pay F click FF er respect that's what it
is word for word press f to pay respects
respects
oops but I put F press and Google
did you play that game something I did
that was one of the ones it was either
advance or infinite warfare I've played
all the cards with the exception put
every cot except for block opposite to
because my copy of black ops 2 got
stolen oh no I love black ops always a
lot of zombies on that but I never knew
campaign oh and I haven't played backup
Street but I played literally every
other cop okay so this is the cops
that's what it was
press f to pay respects had the five
year anniversary like last week or
sometimes that's or it became in a meme
instantly and it was advanced warfare I
think the last campaign had played now I
took a break but I didn't play advanced
or infinite and then I played world war
2 black ops black ops 3 you may be that
forget there's so many but I play a lot
of them I've always enjoyed Call of Duty
campaigns me too it's always been fun I
was really upset with you know what I
don't think I was ready for it at that
point I played it and I was like ok for
what it is I just wasn't into battle
right after time but now I'm back with a
modern warfare for sure you can't get me
off that game damn oh no was it did we
see a side path yeah and I missed the
quack
[Music]
woo how do we feel about the staying
power of this game of Tim Tim good I
mean until people go through everything
it has to offer right so I'm gonna agree
with you right now it seems like it got
a really strong start people like that
this is a competitor to Game Freak they
like that it's doing some things
different from Game Freak so I you know
overall I welcome it I haven't been
playing as much but I do like as far as
staying power I think it's got a shot to
stick around for a while sure we'll have
to see though down the line oh yeah
evolution asked if does this game have
anything similar to Team Rocket yeah
we're fighting them in the case they
even have little uniforms but I forget
what they're called we might be able to
get to it yeah we got another yeah that
guy's just looking for a bike oh [ __ ]
you found him for him oh yeah I know
Akash I missed the quack yeah I was
looking up f to pay respects it's still
on my screen there we go
I wonder what the rarest Tim Tim is
looks like is there other stats for like
a catch rate cuz you know there are some
like big effect that don't even have any
evolved form I'm thinking of like how
rare are those no we've seen a lot of
piggy picks this one looks cool balázs
vanished a lot it's like a badger fox
thing with cool red hair sorry you guys
can't see this but trust me miss dope is
online required to play this game can
you do it offline as far as I know it is
required
I haven't seen an offline mode for this
game even offered here David yeah maybe
don't quote me all the way on that but I
don't think I think it's online only
we've got some apps per side that yep
sorry Jimmy she says which we hadn't
mentioned the color issues I was having
because now he feels like he's focusing
on it oh no
Chad you want to know something else
you're gonna focus on try not to think
about breathing your kill whenever I do
that and I have to think of everything I
like all these scents me probably yeah
like yeah and everything I know you mean
everything gets irregular you know
what's beeping I had the same problem
funny enough when I got my with my
wisdom teeth removed purchase out today
because she got hers for me but like
swallowing I'm not trying to swallow
extra with like all the cotton in my
mouth and stuff like that
when you think about it you're like I
have the urge to like loop it does it's
awful when you think about it like what
you're talking about with breathing you
have to like you can't think about it
otherwise you're just gonna keep doing
it or like when I was sick and you have
a sore throat and you don't wanna like
also you don't want to swallow there too
because it just stings you I hate that
and then you have to think about not
following it god good thing I've been
knocking on wood haven't been sick in a
while but
I'm a germaphobe totally so I miss it
very often what are the rules oh sorry
now you go first oh I was reading chat
what are the requirements to play this
game buy it right I meant like does he
mean like PC spank
cuz I don't know let me look that up it
looks friendly enough it looks so
approachable it looks doesn't look like
it's a graphically demanding game but
price yeah let me go on krema their
website Akasha is do you guys have any
Pokemon that y'all like that ended up
hating because of the evolutions or lack
there yeah Pokemon that only has one
evolution like it doesn't have two
evolutions upsets the living you know
what I mean like like one like gold duck
zip streak even houndoom like I need
something more what about coffee
well copies that wheezing but again like
yeah but that's - yeah we easy should
have something else right yeah yeah I
don't know it's like that stuff bothers
me I know it doesn't bother a lot of
other people but it bugs me and then
like an OCD thing they gotta have free
it's just cuz like having a final
evolution is always so cool and I always
feel like it could be so much cooler if
these you know second evolutions have
something yeah maybe they were some of
them they kind of held out on or
sometimes there there's like two Pokemon
and then you find out later that like
you there's a a prequel baby and then of
course all the the starters for sword
and shield I thought my I thought were
probably some of the weakest really it's
really unfortunate although I picked
score bunny
with that because incentive or is the
best out of the free like hot take the
water cipher the freaking grass drummer
like come on he's not with it folks okay
I'm on the steam page I'm trying to find
out the specs to run this game normally
steam is good about telling you that
usually Jelena Robert hello to you
welcome oh here we go alright so you
need Windows 10 the 64-bit version at
least ya need four gigs of RAM you need
at least an Nvidia GT 650 or similar
yeah I think you can pull this off [ __ ]
I mean I know I could do it on my Mac
but like I don't know if I should leave
five gigs of available memory space I'm
sorry for storage though that's the
minimum that by the way they have two
tiers here recommended is Windows 10
6100 T 3.2 gigahertz or similar eight
gigs of memory in NVIDIA 970 or similar
broadband internet connection by gigs of
storage space yeah that's if you want to
play at 1080 60 FPS the other one
requirements were for seven twenty
thirty frames which is fight for this
kind of game like come on man doesn't
even have now like six or more in my day
there were three David eight actually
damn Larry on Vaporeon Jolteon Umbreon
SP on LaCie on VPN
yeah that's a damn oh did I miss another
quack-quack damn it nothing said I think
it was final we're fighting crystal and
that one weird like okay
Oh busted
yeah dude I wonder what the end game
looks like who I've seen a lot of this
the beginning of the game from alpha and
this and when I played it too but uh
further on down the line we've made it
to one dojo though that was Derek says
just waiting on Dragon evolution nah I
need it I bet there's deviantART of that
all over there for sure there's a lot of
types there's no rock round Eevee oh
yeah there's fan art for Dragon type so
you're not alone man that one looks like
legitimate actually because they cut the
wage color sorry you can't see my screen
but it's out there y'all Derek you are
not alone oh gosh they keep saying I
keep missing the quacks no I mean when
I'm fighting side Pat's are we no no or
maybe we were
[Laughter]
[Music]
Oh houndoom is a mega evolution I
remember that name from Pokemon go
[Music]
can we interact with another player
never request from chat maybe my rage
yeah I don't see why we evolution asks
what are the things which you hate about
Pokemon but this game fulfilled hmm
that's a specific question I don't know
because I actually don't hate say that
like I mean you know the online can be a
little lacking in Pokemon and clearly
there's a lot of focus on online here so
I'm sure they do it better the trouble
is is that in games like this I'm not
really an online player you nana mean
mm-hm so I'm not quite that that market
really be like looking like oh yeah what
I really want is like a great online
experience and again what it's like I'm
just I just want a little up my temp
sense I just want to make them maximum
out beef em up
Oh a big a big Go Diego Go since early
access yeah pick up X about to get rekt
no just capture him save him that's it
I'm what it streams over you guys I
can't handle this anymore just kidding
[Music]
walked out complete Riggs nah got a
level up your crystal and stuff for the
greater good
yes this game actually can I confirm
that this game is early access so yes it
is wanted to confirm that with chat here
get instant access to start playing get
involved this game as it develops it's
an exciting time seems like whatever
they change it's gonna happen as in play
so it's not gonna be like you have to
buy another early access version use us
yeah that price hail no all reviews on
Steam are very positive so this is going
good so far
[Music]
I wonder how long it takes to capture
all temptin are they even allowed to
make a game so similar to Pokemon looks
like a job or a question for the legal
eagle from the Muppets now what's his
name is it Lee you know I'm talking
about no I I mean it's just funny
because this is like this is like you
clearly having your yeah like ogee
moments of it no what's theme for the
Muppets uh boy it's not like a doofus
I'm sure more than normal
no that's the name yeah legal legal
he's like a patriotic muppet super
grumpy look he's got the unibrow but
yeah apparently it's fine because Pete
they're charging people for this and no
one's going to court yet as far as I
know did we see the temptin anime
trailer yeah the trailer for this game
yeah we did Persia and I did it on
streams when we were waiting to get in
right yeah we'll plant what platforms
this game having early access release so
far only PC my friend it's only
available on Steam but we read off the
specs if you're cool with playing at
720p and 30 frames per second you can
play this online yeah yep oh I like that
one on the right
you come out you come cool
Sam the Eagle people are saying
confirming cuz I kept saying legal eagle
I don't know where I got that from chats
got my back though for sure yeah Sam
Eagle oh no you almost got both of these
guys though
oh that screamed yeah yeah what's called
shrill voice take them both down did
y'all know coughing and wheezing other
forms akaash no I do not I only know
those two so I don't know about coughing
another really yeah it's cool actually
would you say a gallery' employee
Oh Larry Bob Jones welcome back to the
tail end of the joke it is running a lot
better today it's were being here man
which is nice
oh yeah these are like smoke stacks on
cut on his gallery' inform yep
I'm learning a lot today essentially the
thing is is that I feel like what made
Pokemon so iconic wasn't just the game
it was the show the trading cards a
trading cards the movie the God ways
like you know there's so much it's kind
of like saying the Star Wars become
iconic yeah guys by the movie itself but
also growing up with like action figures
and Legos I mean there's so much more
than just it was a lifestyle bro it
became a passion and it still is so I
mean she this might take this might this
might launch in the same way but I don't
know
it's it's too early to tell right now by
the way you're fighting Aaron Carter
from like 1997 look at that haircut oh
my god got the center part and
everything Oh Derek in the chat says I'd
love a temp temp trading card game would
definitely play yeah sure
cool I love trading card games although
okay let's go Pokemon
I got a setup with this I am NOT a fan
of the state of the trading card game
currently okay it bothers me so much the
way that they are like all these Pokemon
get retcon didn't like read on and look
at newer generation and it's like damn
it ruins the value of it the og cards
the first like three generations of
cards were so good so iconic that it
actually mattered and now I feel like
what are your guys thoughts you guys
keep up with pokemon cards in the chat I
did for like what you said Jen one
through maybe two
yeah I am I buy them like individually
online because it's like I paid like
three anywhere from like 25 cents to
like 18 bucks for a card just sayin
collection
this is something I might want to pass
down hell yeah generations but like I
look at it now and I'm like this is
gonna be irrelevant
I don't know man
we'll see I mean my forgot what I do
with my first mic all my pokemon cards
but I will chime in and say that I did
not actually play the game the card game
I just like to collect them yeah man I
had a story it still kills me to this
day I was really into collecting pokemon
cards around the age of 10 right and
then we went to this like baseball card
shop my neighbor and I across the street
and I was getting her into Pokemon cards
she bought a regular blue starter pack
with like whatever comes with like 12
cards
she got a holographic Charizard in her
very first pack I was like boy I was so
jealous a Gen 1 and I was like you I
don't think you understand the severity
of this she's like cool look at this one
I was like I struggled for years with
that I wonder what she did with that
card
you know you yo yeah yo s was hey
but again but like you know got way too
complicated
later on like when I pull out a card and
I see half the card is just text and I'm
like Jesus homework man so I don't know
you know what I like the theme song of
the show cuz it gets me hyped like dick
and they had that cool thing you know
it's called
that arm piece the problem was is that
when you look at the show now so much of
you goes like flashbacks mm-hmm like
someone pulls out a card and it's like
you was activating my trap card an
entire episode like oh no I can't flash
back man
maybe I don't know how you guys like
yugioh in the chat you guys like to show
the trading card game I'm I know we
gotta have some fans for sure words ask
what's the slogan for this game gotta
fetch them all no no I don't know what
is didn't even have one probably not
here we go so this this is the villain
they're called belt Belle sotto sotto
Scouts oh they had a weird name yeah
these are like the team rocket
equivalent they're here all right
awesome
yeah that's what they look like ah
action the chat says I should have
swapped all my pokemon cards for that
Hollow I know man I know I should have
done it I shouldn't be like I'll take
that little dragon card off here for
five bucks I don't know what kind of
sucks but I don't have it you know
should have lied to you Brittney I
should have lied Derek in the chat says
I still collect the cards Bob Jones says
the more text the cards the more okay
more complicated mean magic do you ever
play that I've not like that me either
I think their slogan is tempt him up I
think so that sounds right a lot of
people say that yeah
that's crazy Szczecin lighting
apparently damages like both my crystal
and the other enemy but since my dreams
was resistant to electric it seems like
it's a it's worth it oh man
I mean she's almost down yeah I got a
little bit Derrick rubbing it in Chad
says now that card is worth tons of
money I'm gonna look it up right now I'm
just gonna look it up and uh you know
it'll haunt me for the rest of my life
damn it's a first edition charger yeah
it was it's like a couple hundred it's
like and I kept my cards clean it would
have been me damn it
alright I'm gonna look it up right now
[Music]
holographic would you say Jen one yeah
oh my oh my 10 grand on stock ex okay
that's right give my DD Jordans wrong
man you can shout out the stock act
sponsored a sponsor dammit dude they're
like freaking selling uh-oh
charger crisis yeah oh all my heart
that's it that's the one Steven galaxy
we're saying hug one cuz we're looking
at pokemon cards on the other screen you
guys can't see it yeah my screen over
here I'm looking up the worth of the
holographic Charizard Pokemon card
dang
well maybe going wish calm and get like
a a bogus one got him
did the the battle theme change or is
they added another one because remember
there was a super heavy violin one yeah
that one sounded a little more like
action so this is the violin one I think
yeah maybe it's like a location-based
song yeah cos that's exactly how I was
feeling dude the sound of silence by
Simon and Garfunkel's started playing in
my head I'm gonna take this off the
screen right here there I don't need to
see that anymore on my screen oh well
it's not fun collecting those cards yeah
big part of my childhood everyone for
sure Stephen also had the game or he had
the same card if when he was a child
oof we could've we should have held on
to the man you know we all thought it
was a fad Pokemon
[Music]
what about Gyarados oh man I had that
too I actually had that one and kept it
I'm not gonna look up the worth on that
cuz this is just gonna
y'all want to wear me dance Knights a
holographic I mean I just know if their
first edition girl worth more
yeah that's all I had to god I remember
watching the the first Pokemon movie in
the theater you got a Mew card it was
like a new trading card yeah remember it
was from the movies or like McDonald's
or something like that
so you know your boy hooked it up I had
that I'm sure cuz I love McDonald's dad
toys or something there too now they're
still giving away I got cereal like a
few months ago and it came with a
Pokemon card I think I gave it to
calories oh this was a long time ago in
cereal yep
I miss the days of like toys inside
cereal boxes yeah man these went down
quick yeah nicely done so it looks like
we're reaching the end of the stream but
I'll get in one more for you guys here
we go
nice little to be too good either
rain and I'm going to oh I have new
orders from the boss and pretend to be
that Oh sick which was I was like give
me Larry 10 cents all right do you bro
when dozens come out my friend it is out
an early access right now you can play
this first it's on Steam on PC and since
it's early access more will be added
there are still things that are working
work in progress but you can play this
right now you please today how do you
guys feel about the remaking the first
Pokemon movie I thought it was cool but
I don't care for the talking oh yeah
dude that was so controversial forgotten
here's the thing they didn't really
remake the first Pokemon movie right
because that was wasn't that Pokemon mm
it was like the mutant yeah which was
the first movie me two strikes back
right or something like that no yeah it
was first movie with with me too and I
didn't like that wasn't what it was this
time right it was some weird thing with
like ho-oh and like the three legendary
dogs and I was like oh they added the
dogs yeah remember remember in the very
first episode of the anime - oh yeah it
was that but and it was like him bonding
with the Pikachu and all that and I was
like it's not the movie that's like the
first like a couple episodes of yeah
it's like they're right click mixed with
it yeah you're absolutely right who
Akash has did you watch the detective
Pikachu
I have not you have not it's funny I
think you should I was I think I would
like that
I watched it very late though like it
was out of theaters alright
got him swallow this little cocoon thing
oh no I'm gonna end the stream here we
don't need to see this violence no don't
hurt him oh you did double damage and
everything I'll be be back you like get
a little body jump oh here we go
I can't walk I can't watch tell me when
you've defeated piggyback no I'm gonna
hear it I'm taking off my headphones
you're monster just kidding this little
cocoon thing won't die there we go yeah
well we ended on a win yeah we did some
dubs in the chat
on that note friends let me sweet let me
uh there it is thank you guys for
joining us today for a little tempting a
successful run and thanks for joining in
last time we couldn't get in but you
guys stuck it you see guys stuck it out
anyway hung out with us and we
appreciate you guys yes thank you David
that was David playing the whole time he
did great and as for us we're here
Monday through Friday 11:00 a.m. Pacific
Standard Time so come back join us
tomorrow every day every day and every
we have to be here if you're not then my
son Sam will find you that's right
until then we'll see you next time bye
[Music]